الالوان حياه الالوان هي الحياه
يعني انا اكثر ما يميزني يمكن في اعمالي
الالوان الوان جميله الحمد لله
ومتناسقه جدا يعني تشوفيها هارموني مع
عناصر العمل
حلو ولما تفكر ذكيه المتعب في في الرسم هل
تعيش حاله يعني البعض مثلا في الموسيقى
يقول لك والله انا الفنان اعيش بحاله من
الصراع كيف اطلع النغمه كيف
اذهب الى مقام معين كيف احاول ترجمه هذه
القصيده الى الى لوحه غنائيه انت تعيشي
مثل هذه الحاله لما تبداي تفكري في الرسم
ولا الموضوع يختلف هنا
هي كل الفنون واحد ولادتها وحدها صعبه
الولاده صعبه
يعني في حاله مخاض يكون الفنان يعني تبدا
من لوحه ناصعه البياض ثم تضيف عليها
الالوان والخطوط الى مراحل مراحل حتى تخرج
الى
نهايه كما يراها المتلقي فاحنا بنمر بعده
مراحل اكيد مرحله الولاده الفكره يعني
الفكره تكوين هل تكون راضي عنها او لا
وبعدين مقياس الرضا يكون من خلالك انت ولا
من خلال الناس اللي تشوف في مقياسين طبعا
من خلالي انا
الفنانه التي رسمت اللوحه ومتذوق او
الناقد الفني